jaco i have a question after reading
your book
which i thought was one of the best
books i've read since your last book
nice i'm curious what what
you did during your seal team days to
maintain your your schedule
as i would imagine in the teams your
schedule changes at any minute to
include you being deployed
or active during your various missions
at night
so as in life how do you keep your
balance of your schedule when duty calls
in your book you say keep your schedule
but how did you work through this when
you
would be on a mission that didn't allow
you to sleep at night
did you still did you still the
following day upon return maintain your
normal schedule
appreciate your time and response great
yeah obviously the teams
the your schedule and the teams can vary
a lot and you have to adopt to
what makes sense and sometimes in the
teams you're working 18 20 hour days
sometimes out in the field
you're going to the field for two three
four five days at a time
uh sometimes you're working for 24 hours
a day or you work for 36 hours straight
because you do planning in the blah blah
so that can be a problem sometimes
you're doing dives
you're doing two dives a day and that
takes a bunch of time and it takes a
toll on you
it's hard work i guess you could say um
sometimes we're running around all day
or all night running around the desert
running around the urban training
facility
and so the schedule's changing all the
time and it's the same thing with
business
the same thing with business right now i
travel and the flight leaves early the
flight leaves later the work all day or
the dinner with the clients or the
interview or the writing or the
the recording of the podcast or the
changing time zones and things just
change
and so what i do is yes i try and i try
and keep the schedule as much as i can
and if i fall off the schedule for
whatever reason i get back on it as
quickly as possible
and i i think so so yes you do the best
you can
i think the main thing you have to watch
out for is letting
letting a change in schedule or a
problem in your schedule
be an excuse to fall off the path right
that's what you have to watch out for
um you know we think oh i'm in a new
time zone or i've got jet lag or i
didn't sleep well or i need rest from
traveling or i did
this the other night and so i'm going to
sleep until 9 30 tomorrow morning and
just
call it good yeah that's what you have
to watch out for now sometimes do you
need to work till
9th do you sleep until 9 30 yeah
sometimes you do sometimes you stay up
for 36 hours
you go to bed at three o'clock in the
morning guess what
you might need to sleep until 9 30.
that's cool good do it
get some sleep um but just be careful of
using it as an excuse to
go way off the path and just get
yourself back on the path as soon as
possible
yeah make sense yes sir
yeah that's all me right there like one
little thing on my schedule throws off
ah this whole day is gone
i'll do it tomorrow he's gotta be
careful not